Lord inna delgiorno Rekha garrison L
consider a commission a tatiana monitor
a geode le disposition a relative a deer
ET deshita d Nina Lacour Dodi rachet so
the rain you need o rest a canola
Presidente fonder LAN la parola soluti
amo a de la parola al secretary di stato
Nicolina brianna CH prego and no matter
Concilio prego later parola
president honourable members as we are
about to see the withdrawal agreement
enter into force basically unchanged as
compared to its version of 2019 except
provisions regarding Ireland we should
be pleased
in retrospect with our decision not to
accept a care out of the provision on
the citizens rights as requested by many
indeed having done so would have led to
a level of protection far weaker than we
have at present with part two of the
agreement dealing with citizens rights
fully embedded in the whole agreement
and with various remedies were seen
should the UK not deliver adequately in
implementing these provisions this does
not mean that we should rest on the
laurels and I'm grateful for the
European Parliament
for heaven schedule 2 this debate today
I also welcome the draft resolution
table as it lists a number of concerns
regarding the preservation of the
citizens rights the Administrative
Procedure in relation to residence
rights the limited assistance offers to
citizens in this respect or the
effectiveness of the UK independent
authority due to oversee the
implementation of these provisions this
does not necessarily mean that
everything is rosy on the use side it is
important as you note in your resolution
to encourage the Member States to adopt
generous attitude regarding the rights
of UK citizens having decided to settle
in the European Union we should also
insist that both the Commission and the
UK independent authority are rigorous in
their monitoring of the implementation
of part 2 of the agreement there is also
more that can be done regarding the
awareness of citizens on both sides of
the channel however protective of the
provision of the withdrawal agreement
they would be of a little of use to
citizens especially vulnerable ones if
they are not aware of them nor of the
administrative steps needed to benefit
from them and certainly the Parliament
can have a role as well in reaching out
to citizens and contributing to their
information of course all these
provisions even though their effect will
last beyond the transition period will
not cover citizens who would consider
settling in a later stage although we
are well aware that the line of the UK's
government is to put an end to the free
movement of the persons we should make
sure that the future relationship that
will negotiate shortly will be ambitious
enough in terms of mobility this will
have to be accompanied with the
preservation of certain rights for the
citizens concerned let me conclude by
noting the large degree on convergence
that exists between your position of
citizens rights as developed in your
various resolution
and the priorities of the council this
is a clear illustration of the
commonality of purposes of our two
institutions as regard brexit our common
efforts should contribute to ensure that
the provision of citizens rights
individual agreement allow EU citizens
and UK nationals as well as their family
members to continue to live work or
study in their host country as they have
chosen to do thank you very much for
your attention
grazie de saucé Indianola Presidente von
der Leyen
prego Thank You mr. president
Thank You mr. president and honourable
members last week I was in London and I
had the opportunity to speak to students
about the future of the relationship
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union and after I finished the
speech as always the floor was open to
the students and the audience and the
very first question that came was not
about trade it was not about financial
services it was not about security as
important as these topics are it was of
course about citizen's right and the
same question came back time and again
with different personal twists one came
from a young man who came from Benelux
living in the UK who was of course
worried about his future another came
from a British lady who has an Italian
husband who was worried about his status
what's gonna happen with him and while
the questions may have been subtle
different the reasons for asking them
were always the same people want
certainty about their lives and their
future and certainty about the future of
the loved ones and I'm speaking here
about 3.5 million citizens in the UK who
came from a European Union member states
and about run round about 1 million
British people living elsewhere in the
European Union now these are large
numbers
but behind each of these numbers are
people with their very own personal
stories some are citizens from another
European Union country but they are born
in the United Kingdom others have
arrived later many have married have
children I've gone to university have
started their careers and they work in
the UK and respectively in the European
Union so they teach children they treat
patients they care for the elderly they
work in farms or factories they have
started their own business and provide a
living to many more so whatever their
own personal story is they all have one
thing in common and that is they want to
have peace of mind they want to have a
plan for their futures and the future of
their families and all they want to have
is to feel at home in the place they
call home
therefore honourable members protecting
these citizens right has always been our
top priority from the moment the
referendum result came clear thanks to
the excellent work of Michel Barney and
his negotiation team the withdrawal
agreement provides comprehensive
guarantees for these citizens it gives
them the protection and the certainty
they need it allows them to stay where
they live today under the same
conditions for as long as they want and
without any discrimination based on
their nationality this with rural
agreement and with what we have agreed
on puts of course clear obligations on
the United Kingdom and on the European
Union to safeguard these rights one
thing is to put them on paper and have a
thing is to implement them so once the
house has ratified the withdrawal
agreement our top priority will be to
implement our shared obligations both in
letter and in spirit and for me this is
a legal issue with a moral imperative
good news is that the United Kingdom has
already begun implementing the European
Union's settlement scheme to date about
2.5 million European citizens living in
the United Kingdom have already applied
for resident status most of these people
have now received proof of their right
to remain this is good news but you also
know there are cases some have not and
many more are yet to apply and there are
a number of concerns that have always
been raised there are the famous cases
of the French bakers and the Polish
chefs but shine a light on some of the
issues but seriously there are many
other cases where people are confused or
unable to apply for whatever reasons or
others have received requests for more
proof despite having lived in the
country for 40 years or more so we are
close in contact with the citizens and
the UK authorities on these issues we
need to avoid any discrimination or
added complexity during the application
process we need to ensure that all
citizens especially the most vulnerable
are fully supported throughout the
process and we need the guarantee that
the independent monitoring authority can
act in full independence to deal with
complaints this is of utmost importance
from our side the Commission will keep a
close and vigilant eye on the
implementation we're ready to help
European Union citizens living in the
United Kingdom to ensure they are
properly informed and supported and of
course we will do the same when it comes
to British citizens living in the
European Union all these questions I've
been speaking about I've raised with the
Prime Minister Johnson last week when I
visited London we will closely cooperate
with the United Kingdom to make sure
that we can get this right and that we
can solve any problems as
swiftly as possible finally honorable
members the good news is that there will
be continuity for the European Union
citizens living in the United Kingdom
and vice-versa for the British citizens
living in the European Union at the end
of the transition period but after the
end of the transition period the United
Kingdom will be a third country and
brexit will mean changes to those who
will want to make their future life on
either side of the channel we will have
to negotiate a new way forward and we're
getting ready to formulate the mandate
for those negotiations ahead of the 1st
of February we have as we have done in
the past we will in these negotiations
also make the citizens rights our main
priority and we will always negotiate in
good faith to build a new comprehensive
partnership with our British friends as
I've said to those students in London
it's the good old story about old
friends and new beginnings thank you
[Applause]